Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Before we dive into our conversation, I want to remind you, our listeners, that we love to hear from you. If you have any comments, questions, or ideas for us, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-org. Now on to the conversation. We all want to find meaning in our lives, our reason to get up in the morning, yet doing so may not be so easy.
你好，欢迎收听《心理学之声》，这是美国心理学会推出的一档双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。在我们深入探讨之前，我想提醒各位听众，我们非常乐意听到你们的声音。如果你有任何意见、问题或想法，请发邮件至 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A-A-A-D-org。现在进入我们的对话。我们都想在生活中寻找意义，寻找早晨起床的理由，然而要做到这一点或许并不容易。
What is meaning in life and how do we find it for ourselves? Our guest is Dr. Clara Hill, an APA fellow and professor of psychology at the University of Maryland. Dr. Hill recently published a book, Meaning in Life, a Therapist's Guide, which assists therapists as they help clients find meaning in their lives. Today's conversation will examine the concept of meaning in life and ways to find it. Dr. Hill. Thank you. It's delightful to be here. So there's a lot of talk out there about finding one's purpose or calling, passion, you know, meaning in life. So what are your thoughts about those conversations that are happening out there in the world? Well, I think it's terrific because I think people really need
人生的意义是什么？我们又是如何为自己找到它的？我们的嘉宾是克拉拉·希尔博士，她是美国心理学会会士兼马里兰大学心理学教授。希尔博士最近出版了一本新书《人生的意义：治疗师指南》，旨在协助治疗师帮助来访者寻找人生的意义。今天的对话将探讨人生的意义这一概念以及寻找它的方法。希尔博士，谢谢你。很高兴来到这里。那么，现在有很多关于寻找目标、天职、热情，也就是人生意义的讨论。你对目前在世界上发生的这些讨论有什么看法？嗯，我认为这太棒了，因为我认为人们真的需要
to focus on finding meaning in life. And the emphasis on it is even more now than I think it used to be, which is interesting. I think in the past, people often just took their meaning in life. And the as their religion or their job and didn't have much opportunity to think about it. I think they still had meaning in life. It's just they didn't have an opportunity to have as many choices about meaning in life. And I think particularly as religion declines and as job security is so flexible, I think people really have to spend a lot more time trying to think about what did they want in life and how are they going to go about getting it.
专注于寻找人生的意义。现在对这一点的强调甚至比过去更多，这很有趣。我想在过去，人们往往只是接受他们既定的人生意义，将其视为自己的宗教或工作，而没有太多机会去思考它。我想他们当时其实也有人生的意义，只是他们没有机会在人生意义上有那么多的选择。我认为，特别随着宗教的衰落和工作安全性的极具灵活性，人们真的必须花更多的时间去思考他们到底想要什么样的人生，以及他们将如何去实现它。
Is meaning in life an eternal question? Have people always searched for a meeting in life, or is that something that's happening because of our modern world today? Well, I think it is something that people have always searched for, because by the nature of our cognitive development, when we try to figure out how to make sense of the world, I think that's why religions develop. People had to figure out what they're here for and what the purpose is. So I think it's something we've always struggled with. I think sometimes, especially in the distant past, it was up to other people to decide for us what our meaning was. And I think, again, as more technology, as more times have changed, I think we have more the ability to decide for ourselves what we want our meaning to be.
人生的意义是一个永恒的问题吗？人们是否一直在寻找人生的意义，还是这只是我们现代世界所带来的现象？嗯，我认为这是人们一直在寻找的东西，因为从我们的认知发展本质来看，当我们试图弄清楚如何理解这个世界时，我认为这就是宗教发展的原因。人们必须弄清楚他们为什么来到这里以及目的是什么。所以我认为这是我们一直在苦苦思索的问题。我想有时候，特别是在遥远的过去，我们的意义是由其他人来决定的。而我认为，随着科技的发展和时代的变迁，我们更多地具备了由自己决定我们希望生命意义是什么的能力。
Yeah, absolutely. So it's, I mean, it's something you've probably seen in, you know, ancient, probably in the Bible or ancient texts of these questions about like, what is our purpose here? what are we doing here in this world? And I think the answers were more clear-cut, your purpose is to fulfill God's will. But, you know, and that was really good, and there's plenty of evidence that people who are religious and have a spiritual sense are happier and have more meaning.
是的，绝对是这样。我的意思是，你可能在古代，比如《圣经》或古代文献中看到过这些问题，关于我们在这里的目的是什么？我们在世上到底在做什么？我认为当时的答案要明确得多，你的目的就是履行上帝的旨意。你知道，这其实很好，而且有充足的证据表明，有宗教信仰和精神感知的人更快乐，也拥有更多的人生意义。
But that doesn't work for everybody. Now, another point in interest, we talked about people having purpose, but you can also think about other animals, like dogs and horses particularly. there's a lot written about feeling a need to have a purpose to feel like they're doing something important. Dogs get trained to help people. Right.
但这并不适合所有人。另一个有趣的观点是，我们讨论过人们拥有目的，但你也可以考虑其他动物，比如狗和马。有很多文章写到它们有一种需要拥有目的感的需求，觉得自己正在做一些重要的事情。狗经过训练可以帮助人类。没错。
So it's not just people, but it is a level of cognitive development. And I think people certainly have had to talk about it more. So that makes a difference. Yeah, it's fascinating about animals. I hadn't thought about that. But if you think about, you know, what makes a dog happy is kind of like having a job to do or, you know, sniffing. I mean, which is probably in their minds. checking out the environment or keeping the family safe or, you know, guide dog, that sort of thing.
所以这不仅限于人类，它也是一种认知发展水平。而且我认为人类当然需要更多地讨论它。所以这有所不同。是的，关于动物的这一点太迷人了。我之前没有想过这一点。但如果你想一想，你知道，什么会让狗快乐，就有点像有一项工作要做，或者嗅闻。我的意思是，这可能在它们的脑海里，就是探索环境、保护家人安全，或者导盲犬之类的。
And some dogs, if they're not, like border collies, if they're not, they don't have a job, they kind of go a little nutty. Yeah, or some, you know, huskies, actually, I think, the working type of dogs. Exactly. A smaller, you know, maybe like a very small dog might not as much, like a toy poodle or something. But still, I think there's that sense of innate sense in many animals to do. Right. And I think it really does go with our cognitive development, because you can see it in children.
有些狗，如果它们没有工作，比如边境牧羊犬，如果没有工作，它们就会变得有点疯狂。是的，或者有些哈士奇，实际上，我认为那是工作犬的类型。完全正确。而一只较小的狗，也许像非常小的狗可能就不会这样，比如玩具贵宾犬之类的。但尽管如此，我认为许多动物内心深处都有那种本能的做事冲动。是的，而且我认为这确实与我们的认知发展息息相关，因为你可以在儿童身上看到这一点。
little children still want to have something to do, but, you know, as you start thinking about it more, it's the ability to think, and especially as you get into being an adolescent, you know, the feelings about meaning in life, kids want to know what they're going to do with their lives. So it becomes a very much of a crisis period to think about what am I going to do. And then in middle age, it becomes a period of, well, am I doing what I want to be doing? And then as you get older, it's have I done what I wanted to do? What's next? And then I think death anxiety clearly figures into that because if when we die, we want to feel like we've accomplished something. And, you know, death is, it's going to happen to all of us.
小孩子仍然希望有事情可做，但是，随着你开始更多地思考，这就是思考能力，尤其是当你进入青春期时，你知道，关于人生意义的感受，孩子们想知道他们要用自己的人生做什么。因此，思考我该做什会变成一个非常典型的危机时期。然后到了中年，它变成了一个时期，即：我做的是我想做的事吗？再然后当你变老时，就是：我做了我想做的事吗？接下来是什么？然后我认为死亡焦虑显然也是其中的一部分，因为如果我们死后，我们希望觉得自己已经取得了一些成就。而且，死亡是迟早会发生在我们所有人身上的事。
Yes, let's touch on that a little bit. How does meaning in life change across the lifespan? Like you mentioned children and then teens and adolescents and then, you know, budding adults and then middle age. It seems like there's meaning in life could change around the lifespan. Absolutely. Well, I think another thing is important is to think about it's not like something you attain. It's something you're always working on. So you can have one big thing like you can have your career set.
是的，让我们稍微谈谈这个。人生的意义是如何随着生命历程而改变的？就像你提到的儿童，然后是青少年，然后是刚刚成年的年轻人，再到中年。似乎人生的意义在整个人生历程中都在发生变化。绝对是这样的。嗯，我认为另一件重要的事情是，要意识到这不是某种你一旦达成就一劳永逸的东西。这是你一直在努力的事情。所以你可以有一件大事，比如你确定了职业生涯。
But also I think in every moment and every day we're thinking about what gives us meaning right now. So there's different kind of small M meaning and big M meaning. Yeah, absolutely. I think, you know, I was, uh, the other day, I was just sort of, you know, thinking in my head about the things I had to do when I got home, like making dinner or something like that. And it kind of, you know, begrudgingly. I was thinking about it. But then I tried to connect it with values I have, like having dinner on the table and a healthy meal. And that seemed to help. And that seemed to help. I mean, obviously, it's a very small thing. And it's not what is my purpose here, you know, just just like, you get home from work. You're thinking like I had do all these things before you can kind of have your you time. And, and but that seemed to help. I mean, obviously, it's a very small thing. It's not what is my purpose here, but. Well, no. Well, it. It's. It. It. It. isn't a small thing. I think all these things are important. Even the small things add up a lot. And it's making decisions at each moment about what do I want to be doing. And if you're doing things begrudgingly, your life is worse for it. If you're doing it because you want to take care of yourself, you want to take care of your partner, then you start having a different attitude
但同时我也认为，在每一个时刻、每一天，我们都在思考是什么赋予了我们此刻的意义。所以有不同种类的小M意义和大M意义。是的，绝对的。我想，前几天，我脑子里只是在想，我回家后要做的事情，比如做晚饭之类的事情。我有点不情愿地在想这件事。但我试图把它与我所拥有的价值观联系起来，比如把晚餐端上桌以及做一顿健康的饭菜。这似乎有所帮助。这似乎有所帮助。我的意思是，很明显，这是一件很小的事情。这并不是“我在这里的目的是什么”，你知道的，就好像你下班回家，你脑子里想的是我必须做完所有这些事情，然后你才能拥有属于你自己的时间。但是，这似乎有所帮助。我的意思是，显然，这是一件很小的事情。它不是“我在这里的目的是什么”，但是……不，不。它并不是一件小事。我认为所有这些事情都很重要。甚至连那些小事加起来也非常重要。这是在每个时刻就“我想做什么”做出决定。如果你是心不甘情愿地做这些事，你的生活就会因此变得更糟。如果你这样做是因为你想照顾自己，你想照顾你的伴侣，那么你就会开始拥有不同的态度
and your values fit in there. And it's very important that it fits with values. Yeah. Right. Yes, that did seem to help. And, you know, even something. like cleaning or something like that. Well, we make choices all the time. And so cleaning at some level could be begrudging a task. But if you can think of it as here's something I want to do. And if I don't want to do it, are there other ways around it? Whose standards am I living up to?
你的价值观也契合在其中。而且它与价值观相符是非常重要的。是的。没错。是的，这确实有帮助。而且，你知道，甚至是像打扫卫生这样的小事。嗯，我们一直在做选择。所以在某种程度上，打扫卫生可能是一项令人不情愿的任务。但如果你能把它看作是“这是我想做的事”，如果我不想做，还有没有其他变通的办法？我是在符合谁的标准？
Right. Yeah, that's important to examine, I think even on the small level. Exactly. And I wanted to, if you could explain the difference between meaning in life and meaning of life. Because even as I was writing this, you know, writing, these questions, I was thinking, I kept having to catch myself not saying meaning of life. So can you explain what that is? Absolutely.
对。是的，我认为即使在微观层面上，这也是很重要的检查。完全正确。我想问的是，你能解释一下“人生的意义”（meaning in life）和“生命的意义”（meaning of life）之间的区别吗？因为即使在我写下这些问题时，我也一直在提醒自己，不要说成“生命的意义”。所以你能解释一下那是什么吗？当然可以。
So meaning of life is what is the meaning of life? Why are we here? How did humans come to exist? Is there a ordained purpose for us? Is there a larger meaning of life? Or is it just evolution that brought us to the place we are? So those are kind of the, it's kind of the genesis. of everybody. It's not just me personally, whereas meaning in life is how I construct my meaning.
所以“生命的意义”是：生命的意义是什么？我们为什么在这里？人类是如何产生的？是否存在一个为我们注定的目的？是否存在一个更宏大的生命意义？还是仅仅是进化把我们带到了今天这个位置？所以这些有点像是……万物的起源。这不仅仅是我个人的事，而“人生的意义”则是我如何构建我自己的意义。
Even if I believe that the meaning of life is a religious meaning, I still have to make it my meaning. So it's more something I take on, I construct, and I develop. So it's not even searching for it, because searching for it makes it sound like it's something outside that you go out and find someplace. Whereas I'm saying it's more something we have to construct, we have to make up, we have to decide, we have to choose. And it's within our power, within limitations, because we all have limitations, but it's within our power to choose what our meaning is going to be. And can you talk about how people can find meaning in their lives? I mean, these are very large questions. Very large questions. Well, I think it's the simple thing, in some levels it is
即使我相信生命的意义是一种宗教意义，我仍然必须把它变成我自己的意义。所以这更多是我承担、构建和发展的东西。因此，它甚至不是去“寻找”它，因为寻找它听起来好像它是一个在外面某个地方需要你去发现的东西。而我说这更多是我们必须构建、我们必须编造、我们必须决定、我们必须选择的东西。这在我们的能力范围之内，当然也有局限性，因为我们所有人都有局限性，但选择我们的意义将会是什么，完全在我们的能力范围内。你能谈谈人们如何在生活中找到意义吗？我的意思是，这些都是非常宏大的问题。非常宏大的问题。嗯，我认为这是很简单的事情，在某些层面上，它是
the simple thing of every little thing you do, making a choice. What do I choose to do? What am I getting from that? What meaning do I take from that? And being very reflective and self-aware. I think that's the key to finding the purpose and then finding, am I doing what I want to be doing? And really stopping and reflecting. And I think for most of us, we don't do that reflection on a regular basis. We life kind of takes over and we just kind of go through and do what we have to do for the day. And then when something comes up, some big transition, a death of a parent or a death of a pet or get fired from a job, all of a sudden, then it's like, ooh, what is, you know, then we have the big existential conversations about what is my meaning. So I think, again, it's that every little thing we do as well as the bigger questions about meaning. You know, so you're talking about answering these big existential questions.
通过你做的每一件小事，做出选择。我选择做什么？我从中得到了什么？我从中汲取了什么意义？并且要非常善于反思和自我意识。我认为这是寻找目标的关键，然后去发现：我做的是我想做的事吗？真正停下来反思。我想我们大多数人并没有定期进行这种反思。生活往往接管了一切，我们只是随波逐流，做着我们一天中不得不做的事。然后当有些事情发生时，比如某个重大的转变——父母的去世、宠物的离世，或者被公司解雇，突然之间，就会觉得“哦，这是什么……”，然后我们就会进行深刻的存在主义对话，探讨我的意义是什么。所以我想，这同样关乎我们做的每一件小事，以及关于意义的宏大问题。你知道，所以你刚才说的是回答这些宏大的存在主义问题。
Do those tend to come around when you have a life change? Yeah. Okay. Can you talk about that a little more? Yeah, I think it's either at points of regular life developmental kinds of tasks, like emerging adulthood, finding a job, finding a partner, middle age, old age, or it's because of transitions that happen like you get stuck in a tsunami or you have a death or you get traumatized by a rape or something like that.
这些问题往往会在你经历生活变故时出现吗？是的。好的。你能多谈谈这一点吗？是的，我认为它要么出现在常规生活发展任务的节点，比如初显期成年、找工作、找伴侣、中年、老年；要么是因为突如其来的转变，比如你被海啸困住，或者经历了亲人离世，或者受到强奸等创伤。
And then all of a sudden, everything you've thought of in the world as the just world, the things are the way they are, gets disrupted. And you have to stop and think. I can remember when my father died, I remember sitting in a coffee shop and just like, it felt like the world had stopped. It's like, how could these people keep going? It's like nothing makes sense anymore. And I think especially when something doesn't make sense, that disrupts us.
然后突然之间，你对世界上的一切看法——比如世界是公正的、一切都是它原本该有的样子的信念——就被打破了。你不得不停下来思考。我记得当我父亲去世时，我记得我坐在一家咖啡馆里，那种感觉就像世界停止了转动。我就想：这些人怎么还能继续生活下去？感觉一切都说不通了。我认为，特别是当某些事情说不通时，这会打破我们的平衡。
And it makes us stop and think. And lots of times we just cover over that and just we can't handle it. So we just run away. But so, I mean, there's that feeling of this is too much to handle. And I think the thing is that those existential questions are very difficult. But that's the golden time. That's really the opportunity to stop and think. evaluate, is this the way I want to be spending my life? Because we only have a certain amount of
它会让我们停下来思考。很多时候，我们只是把那种感觉掩盖起来，因为我们无法承受。所以我们选择逃避。但是，我的意思是，那种感觉是“这实在太难承受了”。而我认为关键在于，那些存在主义问题非常难。但那是黄金时期。那真的是停下来思考、评估这是否是我想要度过一生的方式的绝佳机会。因为我们在这里的
time here. So it's really a gift, those moments, as hard as it can seem at the time, whenever likely you're dealing with a challenging situation. Well, it's an opportunity. An opportunity. Yeah, right. I don't know if I'd ever, some of those things, I don't think I'd ever say as gifts. Yeah. Maybe looking back, you could say that was an opportunity and we'd be like a, you know, one of those pivotal points in life. Pivotal points. On the other hand, sometimes events are so hard that they do destroy us. Yeah. But some,
时间是有限的。所以这些时刻真的是一份礼物，尽管在经历时看起来可能非常艰难，无论你什么时候可能都在应对充满挑战的情况。嗯，这是一个机会。一个机会。是的，没错。我不知道我是否曾经把其中一些事情称为礼物。是的。也许回过头来看，你可以说那是一个机会，它就像是生活中的转折点之一。转折点。另一方面，有时候事件是如此艰难，以至于它们真的摧毁了我们。是的。但有些，
some events are good enough that are opportunities to help us rethink what we want. Kind of like a pivot point. Mm-hmm. Exactly. Yeah, that's really, that's really fascinating. I mean,
有些事件足够好，它们是帮助我们重新思考我们想要什么的机遇。有点像转折点。嗯。完全正确。是的，这真的很迷人。我的意思是，
that how, that these big events could could really drastically change, you know, call into question your meaning. Right. So if you have a traumatic situation happen, that does call into question
这些重大事件如何能够彻底改变，你知道的，甚至对你的人生意义提出质疑。没错。所以如果你遭遇了一场创伤性的情况，那确实会让人对
the meaning in life that you had believed in before that, what do you do? You have to think really long and hard about, you know, what does this mean? I think most people go into those kind of situations and they think, for example, that there's a just world. And when they learn that the world isn't just, that the world is unfair, that's traumatic. That's devastating in many ways. And having to come back to that and incorporate that into your way of thinking.
你之前所坚信的人生地意义产生质疑，你该怎么办？你必须花很长时间认真思考，这究竟意味着什么。我想大多数人进入那种情况时，例如，他们认为世界是公正的。当他们得知世界并不公正，世界是不公平的时，那是创伤性的。在许多方面，那是毁灭性的。你必须重新面对这一点，并把它融入你的思考方式中，
and not give up, but to say, well, within the limbs of what I can do, what can I do? You know, how can I deal with this? How can I prosper within my set of limitations? Yeah. So, yeah, if you do run across a situation where you do feel like the world isn't fair, are you sort of saying that the thing to keep going and to keep going and to keep? Well, I don't like... Asking the hard questions.
而不是放弃，而是说，在力所能及的范围内，我能做些什么？你知道，我该如何应对？我如何在我的种种局限中繁衍生息？是的。所以，是的，如果你确实遇到了一个让你觉得世界不公平的情况，你是在说要坚持下去，继续前行，继续……嗯，我不喜欢……提出那些难题。
Yeah, I don't like the idea of just keep going. You know, I think that denigrates the difficulties. I think the thing is to really stop, pause, and reflect. You know, if there's any theme and everything I'm going to say, it's the self-awareness, reflection, thinking about oneself. The problem is, for many people, that's really hard. You know, and that's why therapy is so valuable,
是的，我不喜欢那种“只要坚持下去”的想法。你知道，我认为那贬低了困难。我认为关键在于真正停下来、暂停并反思。你知道，如果我要说的一切有什么主题的话，那就是自我意识、反思、思考自己。问题是，对许多人来说，这真的很难。你知道，这就是为什么心理治疗如此宝贵，
because it's really nice to have the supportive person who will listen to you and help you explore non-judgmentally. Most of us didn't have that as children. And so, you know, having that person there who will listen to us is really important because these are things we don't want to look at. We've often been trained not to look at them. And so it really helps to have someone nearby who you can talk to about it. Yeah, absolutely. It's something like a mirror, you know. obviously highly intelligent, highly intelligent, trained to mirror, but it, a reflection of
因为有一个支持你的人倾听你，以不加批判的方式帮助你探索，这真的是一件很棒的事。我们大多数人在童年时都没有得到过这样的对待。所以，你知道，身边有一个愿意倾听我们的人真的很重要，因为这些都是我们不想去面对的事情。我们经常被训练成不去面对它们。因此，身边有一个你可以与之交谈的人真的很有帮助。是的，绝对的。这有点像一面镜子，你知道的。显然非常聪明，受过专业训练的镜子，但它是一面反映
of you and your attitude. Exactly. So because what you're trying to do is figure out what you want. Because, again, so much of the time as children, we do what we're told to do. And we don't, and so that moving from being told to figuring out on our own, who we are and what we want, because nobody can tell you that. It's something you have to struggle with to do on your own. And the more you put it off, the harder it gets, but the more important it is.
你以及你的态度的镜子。完全正确。因为你试图做的是弄清楚你想要什么。因为，再次强调，在成长过程中，我们有那么多时间都在做被告知要做的事情。我们没有……所以从“听从指挥”转变为“自己去弄清楚我们是谁、我们想要什么”，因为没有人能告诉你答案。这是你必须自己去挣扎才能做到的事情。而且你越拖延，它就越困难，但它也就越重要。
So if you think if you do put it off, does that lead to maybe something like a crisis later in life? Absolutely. Yeah. Absolutely. Or profound regrets at death. Right. And that sounds very scary. I mean, if I just think about that right now, if you're, it is too late.
所以如果你认为你把这事拖延了，这会导致以后生活中的某种危机吗？绝对会。是的。绝对会。或者在临终时留下深深的遗憾。没错。听起来很吓人。我的意思是，如果我现在去想这个，如果你正处于那个阶段，那就太迟了。
I mean, there's a lot of times we say, you know, these motivational things like, you know, it's never too late to change, which I do believe in. but at the same time there will be a moment. There is a moment when it is too late. And sometimes in our final years, we not only die, but we get Alzheimer's or whatever, and it is too late at that point. Right, or you're just ill or something, yeah.
我的意思是，很多时候我们会说一些诸如“改变永远不会太晚”这样的话，虽然我确实相信这一点，但同时也会有一个时刻。确实会有那么一个时刻，那就是为时已晚。有时候在我们的晚年，我们不仅会离世，还会患上阿尔茨海默病或诸如此类的疾病，到那个时候就已经太晚了。对吧，或者你只是生病了之类的，是的。
But you do what you can at the time. And some of us can't do anything more, and that's what we can do. In your book, you write about, there's about five components of meaning in life. and they are a felt sense of meaning, mattering or significance, purpose, goals, and engagement in life, coherence,
但你在当时做了你所能做的。我们当中有些人无能为力，但这也就是我们能做到的。在你的书中，你写到了关于人生意义的大约五个组成部分，它们分别是：对意义的切身感受、重要性或重大意义、目标、目标感（注：此处原文重复了purpose和goals），以及对生活的投入、连贯性，
and reflectivity about meaning. So can you walk us through each component and what that means? Absolutely. So the felt sense is just, most of us, if you ask somebody, do you have meaning in life, they will answer immediately,
以及对意义的反思。那么，你能为我们详细介绍一下每一个组成部分及其含义吗？当然可以。切身感受就是，我们大多数人，如果你问某人“你的人生有意义吗”，他们会立刻回答，
yes or no, or on a 10-point scale, 6, 7, whatever. And it's just a sense that you have. It's often hard to even say what it is. Sometimes, then there's research to show that when you feel good, you rate yourself as having more meaning in life. I don't think it's the same, but I think you actually see that you have more meaning when you feel good. So it's just this felt sense. Mattering and significance is probably in my mind the most important.
“有”或“没有”，或者在10分制下打6分、7分之类的话。这只是一种你所拥有的直觉。通常很难确切说出它是什么。有时，研究表明，当你感觉良好时，你会认为自己的人生更有意义。我不认为它们是一回事，但我认为当你感觉良好时，你确实会看到自己拥有更多的意义。所以这只是一种切身感受。重要性和重大意义在我看来可能是最重要的。
Mattering is mattering to someone else or other people mattering to you, the feeling of my family, my husband, my children, my grandchildren. my students, they matter to me. And I feel like I matter to them. It makes a difference that I'm in the world, that they're in the world. So that's the mattering that if, in fact, there are some, Frank and Frank in their book, Persuasion and Healing talked about how in some African cultures, while when people were thrown away from the tribe, they were told to go away, they were, you know, I can't think of the word, dispelled from the tribe.
重要性是指对其他人重要，或者其他人对你很重要，这种感觉来自于我的家人、我的丈夫、我的孩子、我的孙辈、我的学生，他们对我很重要。而且我觉得我对他们也很重要。我的存在、他们的存在，让这个世界有所不同。这就是那种重要性。如果……实际上，弗兰克和弗兰克在他们的书《说服与治愈》中谈到，在某些非洲文化中，当人们被部落抛弃时，他们被告知离开，他们被……你知道的，我想不出那个词了，被驱逐出部落。
They died. Perfectly healthy people would go out in the forest and die because they no longer mattered. And there's some research on prisoners. The prisoners feel like they don't matter. They feel like they're discards from society. And that feeling of mattering is so crucial to us that, you know, it's kind of like I do have a place in this world. So that's the mattering. And the significance that goes with it is that I've done something significant.
他们死去了。完全健康的人会走进森林然后死去，因为他们不再重要了。并且有一些关于囚犯的研究。囚犯们觉得他们不重要。他们觉得自己是被社会抛弃的人。这种重要的感觉对我们来说至关重要，你知道的，这有点像“我在这世上有自己的一席之地”。这就是重要性。与之相伴的重大意义则是，我做过一些有意义的事。
I have a legacy. think of all the presidents want to leave a legacy. I think we all want to leave a little bit of a legacy. We want to see an obituary that people have remembered us that we were there. We have a tombstone. We can show I was here. I existed. I made a difference, at least for a moment.
我留下了遗产。想想所有的总统都想留下遗产。我想我们都想留下一点点遗产。我们希望看到一份讣告，人们记住我们曾经来过。我们有一块墓碑。我们可以证明我曾来过这里。我存在过。我做出了改变，至少在某个时刻是这样的。
So that's mattering and significance. Then the purpose goals engagement is feeling like you have something to accomplish in life, something that you're doing, you have a purpose of goals, or you have had a purpose of goals, or that you're just totally engaged in something. So, for example, I'm writing a revision of my Helping Skills book. I'm totally absorbed in it. That's engagement. I feel like I have, I'm doing something that matters to me. So that's having a purpose. Lots of times that's taken up with a job, but it can be a vocation, it can be a hobby, it can be volunteering. It can just be doing something for a neighbor's, doing some random act of kindness.
所以这就是重要性和重大意义。接着，目标、志向与投入，是指觉得自己有什么事情要在生活中去完成，有正在做的事，有长远的目标（purpose/goals），或者曾经有过这样的目标，或者你只是完全沉浸在某件事中。例如，我正在编写我的《助人技巧》一书的修订版。我完全沉浸在其中。这就是投入。我觉得我有，我正在做一件对我很重要的事情。这就是拥有目标。很多时候，这被一份工作所占据，但它也可以是一种职业、一种爱好、做志愿者。它也可以只是为邻居做点事，做一些随机的善举。
Yes, maybe it doesn't have to be so, so intense as like a job. Because I think a lot of pressure is out there when I talk about finding your passion or calling. It was a lot of great motivational speakers and people talk about what they've learned, how they've been successful. But I think sometimes that can be somewhat overwhelming. People can look at you as an idol, but also, okay, if you're not in the same, If you're feeling the same way about your kind of your work or something, that might be scary. Yeah.
是的，也许它不必像一份工作那样强烈、那样剧烈。因为我觉得当我谈到寻找你的热情或天职时，外界存在着很大的压力。有很多伟大的励志演讲者和人们谈论他们的所学以及他们是如何成功的。但我认为有时这可能会在某种程度上让人感到压抑。人们可能会把你视为偶像，但同时，如果你没有处于相同的状态，如果你对自己的工作或类似的事情有着同样的感受，那可能会让人感到害怕。是的。
And I think for all of us, it's like if I haven't done a cure for cancer, you know, writing a book of meaning in life, that's not the same as curing cancer. If I'm not Carl Rogers or Sigmund Freud, you know, am I anything? It's like it's all or nothing. We have to be famous. Right. Yeah, there's definitely that pressure. He said to be well known or something.
我想对我们所有人来说，这就像是如果我没有治愈癌症，你知道的，写一本关于人生意义的书，那和治愈癌症是不一样的。如果我不是卡尔·罗杰斯或西格蒙德·弗洛伊德，你知道的，我还算什么吗？这就好像是非此即彼。我们必须成名。对的。是的，确实有那种压力。他说要出名什么的。
It was like, well, you can make a difference. And how many people are well known? You know, does that mean only a few people can have meaning? And it's not. You know, you can have meaning by doing a good pot of soup kind of thing. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Or just like you said, anything, helping a neighbor out or being there for a friend doesn't have to be so serious as you're, you know, you're a president of the United States or you're a, you know, chart topping singer. Right. That's a lot of pressure. That's a lot of pressure to live up to. It's way too much pressure. And that's, it's external pressure. And that's a big thing is that's something from.
这就好比，你可以发挥作用。有多少人是成名的？你知道的，这是否意味着只有少数人才能拥有意义？并不是的。你知道的，你可以通过煮一锅好汤之类的事情来获得意义。是的，是的，完全正确。或者就像你说的，任何事，帮邻居一个忙或者陪伴朋友，都不必像你是美国总统或是排行榜冠军歌手那样严肃。这压力太大了。要达到那样的标准压力太大了。压力实在太大了。而且那是外在压力，这是一个很大的问题，那是来自……
the outside because that's something you can't control. We can control, again, within our limits, because we all have limits. We can make choices within those limits. And that, you know, so I might not be Sigmund Freud, but I can be Clara Hill. And maybe that's going to have to be good enough. So the next one is coherence. And actually, this one was the hardest one for me to kind of grab hold of it first. But it's kind of making sense out of the world. It's, again, where where do I fit in the world? Does the world make sense? What, how does, it's kind of like what we think of in therapy as insight,
外界的东西，因为那是你无法控制的。我们能够控制的，同样是在我们的极限之内，因为我们所有人都有局限性。我们可以在这些局限性之内做出选择。所以，你知道的，我可能不是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德，但我可以成为克拉拉·希尔。也许这就足够好了。接下来的一个是连贯性。事实上，这个对我来说一开始是最难掌握的。但它有点像理清这个世界的头绪。它同样是关于我在世界上处于什么位置？这个世界有意义吗？这……这如何……这有点像我们在治疗中所认为的洞察力，
kind of getting insight into me, myself, my place in the world, how I fit. And we all want some sense of coherence. So people like trees that are in orderly rows more than random because that makes them feel like there's coherence. And even if there's not coherence in the world, even if it is, and I do believe this that from an evolutionary standpoint, it's just in some ways by chance
有点像是对自我、对我在世界上的位置以及我如何契合其中的洞察。我们都希望有一种连贯感。所以人们比起随机分布，更喜欢排成整齐行列的树木，因为这让他们觉得有连贯性。即使世界没有连贯性，即使它是……而且我确实相信从进化的角度来看，我们今天所处的位置在某些方面只是出于偶然，
that we got where we are, it still feels good to feel like there is not just totally random. So feeling that need for coherence. Sense of order. Yeah. And then the final one is reflectivity. And that's thinking about meaning.
但感觉事情并非完全随机，仍然感觉很好。所以感受到了对连贯性的需求。秩序感。是的。然后最后的一个是反思性。那就是思考意义。
And in some ways it feels different from the other ones because the other ones are sources of meaning. But in fact, if we didn't think about meaning, we wouldn't have meaning. So the whole self-reflection and thinking about and pondering and who am I, what do I want, that helps us construct the sense of meaning and take it from those other aspects. So those are the five. So is this something you can do on your own or do you think it's, do you need a therapist? I mean, what do you advise? Well, I think we all do it on our own all the time. And I think that,
在某些方面，它感觉与其他几个不同，因为其他的是意义的来源。但事实上，如果我们不思考意义，我们就不会有意义。所以整个自我反省、思考、沉思“我是谁，我想要什么”，这有助于我们构建意义感，并从其他方面提取它。所以这就是这五个方面。那么，这是你可以靠自己完成的事，还是你认为，你需要一位心理治疗师？我是说，你有什么建议？嗯，我认为我们所有人一直在靠自己做这件事。而且我认为，
think this is in general what much of like dreams is another area I'm interested and we mostly look at our dreams and we think about them ourselves I think it's when we get stuck that it helps to have a therapist I mean it's I think everybody should go to therapy but obviously everybody can't afford it it's not possible but I think it really is mainly when you're stuck when you when you haven't had good parenting and need kind of someone to be there and help you reimagine your life. So I think it's incredibly useful to have therapy, but you have to be ready for it.
我认为这大体上就像是许多……比如梦境是我感兴趣的另一个领域，我们大多自己审视梦境并加以思考。我认为只有当我们陷入困境时，找一位治疗师才会有所帮助。我的意思是，我认为每个人都应该去做心理治疗，但显然不是每个人都承担得起，那是不可能的。但我认为确实主要是当你陷入困境时，当你没有得到很好的抚养，需要有人在那里陪伴并帮你重新构想你的生活时。所以我觉得接受心理治疗非常有用，但你必须为此做好准备。
You have to find somebody that fits with you. But especially when you're stuck. So at these big crisis points, I think it can really be helpful to have somebody there who will listen to you. Yeah, absolutely. In dealing with whatever is going on and then also getting past that
你必须找到一个适合你的人。但尤其是在你陷入困境的时候。因此，在这些重大的危机时刻，我认为身边有一个会倾听你说话的人真的会很有帮助。是的，绝对如此。在处理正在发生的任何事情，然后还要克服……
as you address what it means for your life. Right. You did talk about how when you're, you're feeling happier, you're feeling better, you tend to ascribe that you have more meaning in life or believe that you have more meaning in life. So how does happiness fit into all this? Is being happy, having meaning in life? So are you happy if you have meaning in life? And if you have meaning in life, are you happy? Yeah, that's a great question. And again, I think the research is difficult on this. But, and some people again have found that if you feel good, you'll say
在你探讨这对你的人生意味着什么的时候。没错。你确实谈到了当你感到更快乐、感觉更好时，你往往会认为自己的人生更有意义，或者相信自己的人生更有意义。那么快乐是如何融入这一切的呢？快乐就是人生有意义吗？所以，如果你有人生意义，你就会快乐吗？如果你有人生意义，你就会快乐吗？是的，这是一个很好的问题。而且再次强调，我认为针对这个问题的研究很复杂。但是，有些人再次发现，如果你感觉良好，你就会说
you have meaning. So Ballmeister did a lovely study looking at the fact that happiness and meaning are highly correlated. So they are, for the most part, yes, when you're happy, you feel like you have meaning because I think you see things in your life that you as having meaning. And when you have meaning, I think it makes you happy. But he also found that there's some differences between them. So happiness is more related to pleasure, in the moment, feeling good, like having a good meal, having some good chocolate, whereas meaning is more related to making sense out of things, feeling like you matter, feeling like you contribute. So there are, so he gave a great example of a parenting paradox where parents at the time don't feel very happy.
你有人生意义。因此，鲍迈斯特（Baumeister）做了一项极好的研究，探讨了幸福和意义高度相关这一事实。因此，在大多数情况下，是的，当你快乐时，你会觉得你有人生意义，因为我认为你看到你生活中的事物是有意义的。而当你有了意义，我认为它会让你快乐。但他也发现它们之间存在一些差异。所以幸福更多地与快乐有关，在当下，感觉良好，比如吃一顿美味的餐食，吃点好吃的巧克力，而意义则更多地与理解事物、觉得你很重要、觉得你有所贡献有关。所以，它们……因此他给出了一个很好的例子，即父母的悖论，父母在当时并不觉得很幸福。
Yeah. But it does feel like it's meaningful to raise a child. Or people who are mission. or revolutionaries, they probably aren't very happy because they probably live in miserable conditions for the most part, but they feel like they're doing something that's very, very important. So they're willing to give up immediate pleasure or happiness. They'll sleep in rotten conditions, whatever, so they can accomplish the things they want to accomplish. So related, but you can see some places where they're very distinct.
是的。但抚养孩子确实让人觉得很有意义。或者那些身负使命的人，或是革命者，他们可能并不是很高兴，因为他们绝大部分时间都生活在悲惨的境地中，但他们觉得自己在做非常非常重要的事情。所以他们愿意放弃即时的快乐或幸福。他们会睡在糟糕的环境里，无论如何，以便能够完成他们想要完成的事情。所以它们相互关联，但你可以看出它们在某些地方有很大区别。
Yeah, this is something you have to kind of suss out for yourself. Like are you, right? Or you actually, you know, where it is happiness and meaning in life intersect and where do they diverge? You know, and I think the thing is a lot of people search for pleasure too much. And I think the mad search for pleasure, it feels, it ends up feeling empty. Absolutely, yeah. Whereas the search for meaning, I think, makes you feel like, you know, you're at a point of what can I contribute. I mean, in some ways, some people who have the most difficulty with meaning are people who are too wealthy.
是的，这是你必须为自己弄清楚的事情。比如你是……对吧？或者你实际上……你知道的，幸福和人生意义在哪里交集，又在哪里分歧？你知道的，我认为问题在于很多人过度追求快乐。而我认为这种对快乐的疯狂追求，感觉……最终会让人感到空虚。绝对是的。而寻找意义，我认为，会让你觉得，你知道的，你达到了一个“我能贡献什么”的点。我的意思是，在某种程度上，一些在意义方面遇到最多困难的人反而是那些太富有的人。
You know, you can imagine because they've never had to figure it out. They've had everything handed to them. And so they can feel good, but, you know, are they contributing anything? And again, it's a value. It's certainly my value that it's important to have meaning. Yeah, it's sort of like the Buddhist story about leaving, being born into a kingdom and leaving to find out the true meaning of suffering of life. Exactly.
你知道的，你可以想象，因为他们从来不需要去搞懂这些。一切都是现成送到他们手上的。所以他们可以感觉很好，但是，你知道的，他们有什么贡献吗？再说一次，这是一种价值观。拥有意义很重要，这绝对是我的价值观。是的，这有点像关于离开、出生在一个王国并离开去寻找生命中痛苦的真正意义的佛教故事。完全正确。
And that was more meaning, I guess, probably meaning in life and meaning of life. It might have been a little bit of both, I think, of kind of going off of that. And you bring up a great word, the whole word of suffering. Victor Frankel talked about suffering, how, you know, it's important for us all to be aware of our suffering and think about it and process it. And he said, you don't need to go search for suffering because it's always there. No matter where you are in your life, some of us have far more than others. but we need to make sense of suffering and not try to get rid of it. Yeah, I think that can be challenging.
我想那可能更多的是关于意义，人生意义和生命意义。我觉得这可能两者兼而有之，有点从那里面延伸出来的意思。你提出了一个很好的词，那就是“苦难”这个词。维克多·弗兰克尔（Viktor Frankl）谈到了苦难，你知道的，我们所有人都意识到自己的苦难、思考它并加工它是多么重要。他说，你不需要去寻找苦难，因为它一直都在。无论你的人生处于什么境地，我们中的一些人承受的要比其他人多得多，但我们需要理解苦难，而不是试图摆脱它。是的，我认为这可能具有挑战性。
If you think about, you know, you might feel like, okay, do I'm, you know, I think I've struggled with this with this question too. You sort of feel like other people have it so much worse, you know, but, you know, I shouldn't be, you know, thinking so much about challenges in my life. But I guess I've tried to come to the realization and I try to tell myself, that, you know, I can't be in another person's situation. I can certainly have empathy and sympathy and, you know, see what I can do to help. But I also have, if I don't address the challenges in my own life,
如果你去想，你知道的，你可能会觉得，好吧，我……你知道的，我想我也在为这个问题苦恼。你有时会觉得别人的处境要糟糕得多，你知道的，但我或许不应该过多地去想我生活中的挑战。但我想我已经开始意识到，并且我也试着告诉自己，你知道的，我无法身处另一个人的境遇中。我当然可以有同理心和同情心，你知道的，看看我能做些什么来帮忙。但与此同时，如果我不去解决自己生活中的挑战，
right. I'm probably not doing much for myself. Right. Yeah, I think we can't, in some ways, all we can answer to is what, who we are and what we can contribute. Now, I think another point, though, is that we ought to, I think a very valuable part of meaning is for social. justice to try to help other people who aren't as privileged as we are. And there are plenty of
对吧。我可能也没为自己做多少事。没错。是的，我想在某种程度上，我们所能负责的只有我们是谁以及我们能贡献什么。现在，我认为不过还有一点，那就是我们应该……我认为意义中非常宝贵的一部分是为了社会正义，去试着帮助那些不如我们特权多的人。而且有大量的人……
people who aren't privileged. But I don't think we can say, well, I shouldn't feel bad because I have more than they do. It's more being aware of my privileges and finding meaning in trying to help them, trying to change the world. And I think that's what psychology is all about us. Absolutely. Trying to change the world to be a better place. Exactly. Exactly. And one thing you mentioned was talking about if you're trying to search for a meaning in life was to write your own obituary or to ponder meaning in your life can you talk a little bit about that writing that doing that exercise yeah it's a profound exercise i use it in class a lot and to to really realize you know that feeling like i'm on my deathbed and what do i want people to have remembered me for
并不享有特权。但我不认为我们可以说，“哦，我不应该感觉不好，因为我拥有的比他们多”。这更多的是要意识到我的特权，并在试图帮助他们、试图改变世界的过程中找到意义。我想这正是心理学的全部意义所在。绝对是的。努力把世界变得更美好。完全正确。完全正确。你提到的其中一件事是，如果你在试图寻找人生意义，可以去写你自己的讣告，或者沉思你的人生意义，你能稍微谈谈写这个、做这个练习吗？是的，这是一个深刻的练习。我在课堂上经常使用它，为了真正意识到，你知道的，那种“我正处于临终之际，我希望人们因为什么而记住我”的感觉。
there's i think a field called teleology and it's the idea is when we project into the future how we will feel, then we are more engaged in trying to get there. So the idea of what do I want people to think about me, to hear about me, to reflect on me, then I'm more likely to change and go and do it. It's like in a way instigating the crisis that we talked about, you know, so that you have to think about it for a moment. But it's really hard because I think for most of us,
我想有一个领域叫做目的论（teleology），其核心思想是，当我们投射到未来、设想我们的感受时，我们会更加致力于去实现它。所以“我希望人们怎么看我、怎么听我、怎么反思我”这种想法，会让我更有可能去改变并付诸行动。这在某种程度上就像是引发了我们之前讨论过的危机，你知道的，这样你必须花片刻去思考它。但这真的很难，因为我认为对我们大多数人来说，
thinking of an obituary, thinking of death is something we don't want to do. Yeah, absolutely. But it might be helpful to think of like, how would you want to be remembered? Yeah. What things are important to you. And I think somebody once said the whole notion that when they died, they didn't want to have spent any more time in the office. And for me, I was thinking, no, that's not, you know, I feel like the time I spend in the
思考讣告，思考死亡是我们不想做的事情。是的，绝对是的。但思考一下诸如“你想被人们如何记住？”可能会有所帮助。是的。什么对你来说是重要的。我想曾经有人说过这样一种观点：当他们去世时，他们不希望把更多的时间花在办公室里。对我和我来说，我在想，不，那不是……你知道的，我觉得我花在……上的时间
office is I love what I do. So I want to be there. So to be doing what you want to be doing and not later say, oh, I have these regrets. Yeah, that just sounds really isn't. I just, you know, imagine how that would feel this moment in my life. Like, wow, that would be very, you see why elderly people might have some despair in some ways. I mean, obviously it could be from a variety of reasons, but it could be from regrets. But I think also with older people, I think it's very possible really good therapy is
办公室，我热爱我的工作。所以我想要呆在那里。所以做你想做的事，以后才不会说，哦，我有这些遗憾。是的，这听起来真的很不对。我只是，你知道，想象一下，如果在我生命的这个时刻会有什么感觉。就像，哇，那会非常，你看为什么老年人在某些方面可能会有一些绝望。我的意思是，显然这可能有很多原因，但这也可能是因为遗憾。但我认为，对于老年人来说，我认为真正好的心理治疗也完全有可能
helping them recast their lives and go back and look at it. and instead of having regrets for what they didn't do to try to get some perspective on the things they did do that were meaningful. Yeah, they might go into what we were just talking about is how if you're, you know, people, some people might feel like if they're not, you know, Madonna or, or, you know, a president of the United States or a senator. That's all or nothing. Yeah, a revolutionary in the history books that it just, that they didn't do anything. but how many people contributed who are behind those people? It's, you know, untold stories. So I think like you said, recasting your life, that's important too.
帮助他们重塑生活，回过头去审视它。试着从他们确实做过的事中找到一些意义，而不是为他们没有做过的事感到遗憾。是的，他们可能会谈到我们刚才讨论的内容，那就是如果你，你知道，人们，有些人可能会觉得如果他们不是，你知道，麦当娜，或者，你知道，美国总统或参议员。这就变成非此即彼了。是的，历史书上的革命者，如果不这样，就觉得他们什么都没做。但有多少人做出了贡献，却在那些人身后？你知道的，这是不为人知的故事。所以我觉得就像你说的，重塑你的人生，这也是很重要的。
Yeah, and just trying to figure out what can I do, what are my talents, you know, and some people who are multi-talented, that's difficult, but some people who don't have many talents or who are restricted by poverty. I mean, that's really difficult, but still within that to figure out what can I do to make myself and the world a better place. Yeah, and everyone has talents. Everyone has something to contribute. Well, some of them are,
是的，试着去弄清楚我能做什么，我的天赋是什么，你知道的，有些人多才多艺，这很难，但有些人没有多少天赋，或者受到贫困的限制。我的意思是，这确实很难，但即便在那种情况下，也要弄清楚我能做什么来让自己和世界变得更美好。是的，每个人都有天赋。每个人都有可以贡献的东西。嗯，其中一些人是，
lots of us are more limited than others, you know? With everything, do you still believe everyone can contribute something, right? Something. Yeah, something to the world, yeah, to make us leave a better place. Yeah, but it's not necessarily the thing that is socially sanctioned as the best thing.
我们中的许多人比其他人受到更多的限制，你知道吗？不管怎样，你还是相信每个人都能贡献点什么，对吧？某种东西。是的，对世界贡献点什么，是的，让我们把世界变得更美好。是的，但这不一定是被社会公认为最好的事情。
It's more, you know, what fits for me? Like, one of my clients wants to raise dahlias. Oh, the flower, yeah. Yeah. You know, and for her, that's just very meaningful to figure out how to do that. Yeah. You know, and so it's not up to each of us to judge what somebody else does, but to figure out for ourselves what gives us meaning.
更重要的是，你知道，什么适合我？比如，我的一个客户想种大理花。哦，那种花，对。是的。你知道，对她来说，弄清楚怎么做非常有意义。是的。你知道，所以这不取决于我们去评判别人的做法，而是要为我们自己找出什么能给我们带来意义。
Yes, absolutely. How can we encourage other people in our lives that we care about, our parents, siblings, friends, spouses to find a meaning in their life? A question is a really interesting one. I would actually say we shouldn't. Okay. How so? Well, what I mean by that is lots of times we try to change other people.
是的，绝对的。我们怎样才能鼓励我们生命中关心的其他人，我们的父母、兄弟姐妹、朋友、配偶，去寻找他们生命的意义呢？这是一个非常有趣的问题。我其实会说我们不应该这样做。好吧。怎么说呢？嗯，我的意思是，很多时候我们试图改变别人。
I see. And, you know, it's like they're not good enough, so lots of times people get with a partner, that they find a partner, and then they try to change them immediately. Yeah, it's never a good idea. Never a good idea. So I think in some ways what's absolutely the best is you changing.
我明白了。而且，你知道，这就好比他们还不够好，所以很多时候人们和伴侣在一起时，他们找到一个伴侣，然后马上就试图改变他们。是的，这绝不是一个好主意。绝不是一个好主意。所以我认为在某些方面绝对最好的是你去改变。
You know, rather than encouraging other people to change. change, live a life that you want to be leading. And if people ask you, let them know what you're doing. But don't tell them what to do. Don't try to make them do what you want to do. So I think being a model would be more than taking responsibility for your own life. Yeah, that seems to be the one of the most challenging things out there is just taking responsibility for your own life and not trying to change. others or judge others.
你知道，比起鼓励其他人去改变。改变吧，过你想过的生活。如果人们问你，让他们知道你在做什么。但不要告诉他们该做什么。不要试图让他们做你想做的事。所以我觉得以身作则比为自己的人生承担责任更重要。是的，这似乎是最具挑战性的事情之一，就是为自己的人生负责，而不是试图改变别人或评判别人。
Like, I think it's something I could probably say most of us struggle with. Absolutely. Absolutely. Yeah, especially in relationships. You know, we want other people to be happy. We don't want them to be sad. We don't want them to suffer. Yeah, right.
就像，我认为这是我可以打赌我们大多数人都在挣扎的事情。绝对的。绝对的。是的，尤其是在恋爱关系中。你知道，我们希望其他人快乐。我们不希望他们难过。我们不希望他们受苦。是的，没错。
You know, and most people who go into psychology, my students, I see it all the time. They want to help others, you know? And part of that helping is it's helping for them, but it's also making them feel better. But, you know, you can be there and you can be a resource. but that changed other people. Yeah, that's a very fine, fine line, I think, because you want to serve as, I think the idea you just talked about
你知道，大多数从事心理学的人，我的学生，我经常看到这种情况。他们想帮助别人，你知道吗？而这种帮助的一部分，对他们来说是帮助，但这也让他们感觉更好。但是，你知道，你可以陪伴他们，你可以成为一种资源。但去改变其他人。是的，这是一个非常非常微妙的界限，我认为，因为你想作为，我想你刚才谈到的那个想法
is serving as a role model is really powerful and like living, living it yourself, I think is really important because people do pick up on that in your lives. I mean, not everyone, but I think when you see someone who is living the way that you admire or, you know, some qualities you're like, you can take it, see what you like for yourself
以身作则真的很有力量，就像亲身去践行一样，我认为非常重要，因为人们确实会在生活中注意到这一点。我的意思是，不是每个人都会，但我觉得当你看到一个以你钦佩的方式生活的人，或者，你知道，有一些你欣赏的品质，你可以接受它，看看什么是你喜欢的
and take it on for yourself. And not try to be them. Of course, yeah. You know, but that's also the difficulty is, you know, trying to be yourself and figure out who you are. And I don't, we don't have good things in our culture for doing that. Yeah, that's one other question I had for you. I mean, it just seems like our world today is really set up for short term, seeking short term pleasure. And, I mean, although we're, although there are these opportunities to reflect on your passion and purpose,
并为自己所用。而不是试图成为他们。当然，是的。你知道，但这也是困难所在，你知道，试图做你自己并弄清楚你是谁。而且我不知道，我们的文化中没有为了做到这一点而准备好的好东西。是的，我还有另一个问题想问你。我的意思是，在我们今天的世界里，似乎真的很倾向于追求短期快乐。而且，我的意思是，尽管我们，尽管有这些机会来反思你的激情和目标，
there's so many temptations in the short term for, you know, buying things or doing things or consuming media, you know, that just is very materialistic. Yeah, it's very surface. It's not, it doesn't go in depth into these big questions. So is, you know, we do have listeners from other countries, but is American society, which is the one I can speak about because I'm living in America, is it set up for these, these, these answering these big questions and really living a life? that is about meaning.
但在短期内有太多的诱惑，比如买东西、做事情或消费媒体，你知道的，这非常物质化。是的，非常表面。它没有深入探讨这些宏大的问题。所以，你知道，我们确实有来自其他国家的听众，但是美国社会，这是我能谈论的因为我住在美国，它是为了回答这些重大问题并真正过一种关于意义的生活而构建的吗？
Yeah. Well, I don't think so. You know, and I think it's too hard. I think it's easier to figure out, well, what do I want to buy next? What am I going to dress? How am I going to look? What does the neighbor think? But I think these questions about meaning are just, we just want to push them away.
是的。嗯，我不这么认为。你知道，而且我认为这太难了。我认为弄清楚“我接下来想买什么？我要穿什么？我看起来会怎么样？邻居会怎么想？”要容易得多。但我认为这些关于意义的问题，我们只是想把它们推开。
Yeah. So, yeah, I don't think we are set up to do that. Even in therapy, people go to therapy for getting rid of symptoms. Not many people go to therapy to work on existential issues. That ought to be what therapy is mostly about. is these are the big issues that we need to be struggling with. And there ought to be more effort put toward that. Yeah, I've just been kind of pondering that a little bit more.
是的。所以，是的，我不认为我们是为此而生。甚至在治疗中，人们去治疗是为了消除症状。没有多少人去治疗是为了解决存在主义问题。那本该是心理治疗主要关注的内容。这些是我们需要与之搏斗的重大问题。而且应该在这方面投入更多的精力。是的，我只是一直在思考这个问题。
It just seems like there's so much working against you. Yep. You know, and at a podcast I did recently, it was talking about finances and anxiety on the stock market. And I did talk to a psychologist about that. And similar questions came up about just like about, you know, thinking forward and, you know, having a nest egg and delaying gratification. and how important that was.
这看起来好像有太多的阻力在对抗你。是的。你知道，在我最近做的一个播客中，它谈到了财务和股市焦虑。我确实和一个心理学家谈过这件事。也出现了类似的问题，关于向前思考，拥有积蓄，以及延迟满足，以及这是多么重要。
That seems like it even kind of parallels with meaning in life too. In some ways, I mean, obviously, it's different in a lot of other ways. But, you know, we're just, the culture around us makes life makes it challenging. Right. Well, you know, how much money do we need?
这似乎甚至与人生的意义也有某种平行关系。在某些方面，我的意思是，显然，在很多其他方面它是不同的。但是，你知道，我们只是，我们周围的文化让生活变得具有挑战性。对。嗯，你知道，我们需要多少钱？
Yeah. I mean, it's nice to have money. Of course. You need. Totally think. Yeah. But that does not give you happiness. It does not give you meaning.
是的。我的意思是，有钱是好的。当然。你需要。完全认同。是的。但这并不能给你带来幸福。它不会给你带来意义。
And to help people figure that out early on so that children, you know, come to believe that it's, It's what you, who you are, you know, that we need to be good people. We need to be kind people. Yeah, when there's a lot of pressure the other way. So it's just got to go, go against the grain and kind of fight the tide, I think, a little bit. Exactly.
并帮助人们尽早弄清楚这一点，以便孩子们，你知道，开始相信，它是，你是谁，你知道的，我们需要成为好人。我们需要成为善良的人。是的，当有很大压力朝向相反方向时。所以我们必须逆流而上，有点像与潮汐抗争，我想。Exactly.
You know, and along those lines, too, we are seeing, you know, the records of, or the rates of suicide were frighteningly high in the CDC report that was released over the summer. And it was very alarming. How can finding meaning in life help people who might feel those feelings of worthlessness or helplessness or people struggling with severe depression? I mean, we clearly have a crisis going on. We have a problem happening. Well, actually, it is a crisis of meaning. I mean, lots of times people commit suicide because they have no meaning. So it is actually the epitome of that crisis.
你知道，顺便说一句，我们也看到，在今年夏天发布的疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）报告中，自杀记录或自杀率高得令人害怕。这非常令人震惊。寻找生命的意义如何能帮助那些可能有无助感、无望感的人，或者与严重抑郁症作斗争的人？我的意思是，我们显然正在经历一场危机。我们正在发生一个问题。嗯，实际上，这是一场意义的危机。我的意思是，很多时候人们自杀是因为他们觉得生活没有意义。所以它实际上是那场危机的缩影。
One of the groups they talk about mostly is white men, feeling like they used to be the ones in charge of society, and now they're feeling irrelevant. Lots of people are losing their jobs. Robots are going to come in and take away even more jobs. And so what are people going to do? How are people going to find any meaning in their lives? So, yeah, I think suicide is a big one. And I think it's often a big cry for help trying to figure out what our people. places and what we can do. And I think the problem is a lot of times with suicide is people,
他们主要讨论的群体之一是白人男性，他们觉得自己曾经是社会的主宰，而现在他们觉得自己变得无关紧要。很多人在失去工作。机器人将会进来夺走更多的工作。那么人们该怎么做？人们将如何在生活中找到任何意义？所以，是的，我认为自杀是一个大问题。而且我认为这往往是一个强烈的求救信号，试图弄清楚我们是什么人，去什么地方，我们可以做什么。而且我认为问题在于，很多时候自杀是因为人们，
it's like that tunnel vision, they don't see that there's any other possibilities. They're just so beaten down and they give up. And so I think we need to do a lot to help people who are in that place. I mean, I can certainly remember in high school having feelings like that. And I couldn't, I couldn't at the time imagine that there could be a possible different future. You're feeling, feeling helpless? Yeah, just feeling like, this, you know, this is a bad place. I don't want to be here kind of thing, yeah. It's sort of easy to have that happen.
这就像那种隧道视野，他们看不到任何其他的可能性。他们已经被彻底打垮并放弃了。所以我觉得我们需要做很多事情来帮助那些处于那种境地的人。我的意思是，我当然记得在高中时有过那样的感觉。而且我当时无法想象，未来还会有另一种可能的不同未来。你感到，感到无助吗？是的，只是觉得，这，你知道，这是一个糟糕的地方。我不想呆在这里之类的事情，是的。这种事情很容易发生。
You see a lot of the bad things happening around, around. And he said the changing world, too. Changing so fast. Yeah. Where's our place in it? Yeah. I saw an interview you did for the University of District of Columbia, where you talked a little about finding purpose and work
你看到身边发生了许多不好的事情。而且他说世界也在改变。变得太快了。是的。我们在其中的位置在哪里？是的。我看到你为哥伦比亚特区大学做过一次采访，你在那里谈到了寻找工作中的目标
and how automation robots may come into play. Right. And that was interesting to hear that because I think there is a sense of, okay, we want to be doing more meaningful work so we can have a, you know, a automatic cash register or someone at a fast food, you know, someone at the drive-through so you don't have an actual human there. But it does seem like, I don't know if there's, of course, I'm just saying this. I don't know if there's any connection. But with the rise in people out of work and how those relate to feelings of helplessness, Does you have any thoughts about how the changing technology and how that's impacting meaning in life?
以及自动化机器人将如何发挥作用。没错。听到这个很有趣，因为我认为有一种感觉，好吧，我们想要做更有意义的工作，这样我们就可以拥有一个自动收银机，或者快餐店里有人，你知道的，得来速（drive-through）窗口有人，这样你就没有一个真正的真人。但它确实似乎，我不知道是否存在，当然我只是这么说。我不知道这之间是否有任何联系。但是随着失业人数的增加以及这与无助感的关系，你对技术变革及其对生活意义的影响有什么看法？
Is it creating more of a challenge for people to find meaning life? Because if you find meaning in life through work, no matter what it is, what does that do to your spirit? Yeah. I think it's going to have huge problems in the future if so many people don't have jobs and robots are replacing us. And what do we do? What do we do?
这是否给人们寻找生活意义带来了更大的挑战？因为如果你通过工作找到生活的意义，无论那是什么，这对你的精神有什么影响？是的。我认为如果这么多人没有工作而机器人正在取代我们，未来将会有巨大的问题。我们该怎么办？我们该怎么办？
Go and get our nails painted and, you know, is that all that we have? to look forward to and having enough money, you know, where's, where's, how are people going to live? Unless our culture changes dramatically to support everybody. I mean, wouldn't that be wonderful if we actually supported everybody and gave everybody health care and then said to everybody, you know, how can you find meaning? Let's, you know, you don't have to work. You know, what do you want to do with your life? That would be such a different kind of world. Yeah, just one where maybe you explore jobs that are, you know, you know, or you can, you know, use your, your talents in different ways and that sort of thing.
去修指甲，你知道，这就是我们所有的期待吗？并且有足够的钱，你知道，哪里是，怎么，人们将如何生活？除非我们的文化发生巨大改变以支持每个人。我的意思是，如果我们真的支持每个人，为每个人提供医疗保健，然后对每个人说，你知道，你如何找到意义？让我们，你知道，你不必工作。你知道，你想用你的生活做什么？那将是一个完全不同的世界。是的，也许只是一个你可以探索你喜欢的工作的世界，你知道，或者你可以，你知道，以不同的方式运用你的天赋，诸如此类的事情。
Right. Especially if there's a safety net to catch people. But then the whole society has to change. We have to totally revalue what is, you know, to take care of people. I mean, if people don't have dental care and medical care, they can't think about, you know, meaning in life. They just have to survive. Yeah.
对。特别是如果有一个安全网来接住人们。但随后整个社会都必须改变。我们必须彻底重新评估什么是，你知道，照顾人们。我的意思是，如果人们没有牙科护理和医疗护理，他们就无法考虑，你知道，生活的意义。他们只能勉强生存。是的。
And they're talking about the different modes of, you know, how can you get to the self-actual if you're worried about the basic needs. Exactly. And, you know, is, you know, is we think about people around the world who are in that situation, even people our own country. I mean, you know, APA is a deep poverty initiative this year. Right. It's part of our new president.
他们在谈论不同的模式，你知道，如果你还在担心基本需求，你怎么能达到自我实现。完全正确。而且，你知道，当我们想到世界各地处于这种境地的人们，甚至我们自己国家的人民。我的意思是，你知道，APA今年有一个深度贫困倡议。没错。这是我们新总统的一部分。
And we're talking about this deep entrenched poverty that people are dealing with. And how that relates to, to well-being. Yeah. It doesn't feel good. Yeah. Absolutely, yeah. You're in survival mode. You're in survival mode and you feel like you're outcasts from society.
我们在谈论人们正在应对的这种根深蒂固的深度贫困。以及这与福祉的关系。是的。这感觉不好。是的。绝对的，是的。你处于生存模式。你处于生存模式，你觉得自己被社会遗弃了。
Yeah, that's a very big problem. I think the figure I saw recently was like 18.5 million people live in deep poverty. And that's having an income that is half of the federal poverty line. So about an income of about $12,000 for family of four. So it's like how does meaning impact, how does meaning in life impact people from all different socioeconomic statuses? So it's interesting to talk about people feeling wealthy who are, wealthy or having these crises. Right. And people who are in poverty. It's like it's, it's on both ends of the special. It's fascinating. Lots of times the people in poverty, there's such a cycle.
是的，这是一个非常大的问题。我想我最近看到的数字是大约有1850万生活在深度贫困中。也就是收入只有联邦贫困线的一半。所以四口之家的收入大约是12000美元。所以这就像意义是如何影响的，生活的意义是如何影响来自不同社会经济地位的人的？所以谈论那些感到富裕的富人或者正在经历这些危机的人很有趣。没错。以及处于贫困中的人们。这就像它，它处于光谱的两端。太迷人了。很多时候，处于贫困中的人们，存在着这样一个循环。
You know, they have too many kids. They have health problems. They have all this stuff and they have to work three or four jobs. And they just are struggling to hang on. And it's very, very difficult. Absolutely. I mean, there's obviously these questions will linger on probably for the all of humanity. Exactly. Can you touch on, aside from your book, other research, you're doing on meaning in life? I know you've done extensive work on the topic. Well, a couple of things we're doing it. We have a clinic at the University of Maryland, the Maryland psychotherapy, clinic and research lab, and we're everybody, all the clients who come in are filling out measures of meaning and life. And we're actually then going back over some of the sessions in coding when
你知道，他们有很多孩子。他们有健康问题。他们有所有这些事情，他们必须打三四份工。他们只是在苦苦挣扎以求生存。这真的非常非常难。绝对的。我的意思是，这些问题显然可能会一直伴随着全人类。没错。除了你的书之外，你能谈谈你正在进行的关于生命意义的其他研究吗？我知道你在这个主题上做过广泛的工作。嗯，我们在做几件事。我们在马里兰大学有一个诊所，即马里兰心理治疗诊所和研究实验室，所有来到这里的客户都在填写生命意义的测量问卷。然后我们实际上会回顾一些访谈，并进行编码，当
meaning and life gets discussed overtly. And so we can go back and look at when is it, what their topics are that people talk about. So that's some of the stuff coming up in the future, looking at meaning in life. That will be your research topic moving forward. Well, I have a lot of research topics. It's not just meaning in life. As I mentioned, helping skills is one of my big areas. And so one of the passions I have is trying to teach therapists to be good therapist. So I'm doing a lot of work in that right now as well as in psychotherapy and trying to figure out what makes psychotherapy work. So I have kind of several broad areas of interest. Is that people in, are they in the PhD program at Maryland or are they already practicing and they're just doing like refining skills?
公开讨论生命的意义时。所以我们可以回过头来看看是什么时候，人们谈论的话题是什么。所以这就是未来会出现的一些东西，着眼于生命的意义。这将是你未来前进的研究主题。嗯，我有很多研究主题。不仅仅是生命的意义。正如我所提到的，助人技巧是我主要的研究领域之一。所以我拥有的激情之一就是试图教导治疗师成为优秀的治疗师。所以我现在正在这方面做很多工作，在心理治疗方面也是如此，并试图弄清楚是什么让心理治疗起作用。所以我有很多广泛的兴趣领域。是这样，人们在，他们是在马里兰大学的博士项目里，还是他们已经在执业，只是在做类似打磨技能的事情？
No, people who are just beginning like undergraduates take a course in helping skills. Graduate students take a course in helping skills. So it's really trying to figure out how to help them hone skills they have to be better communicators, better therapist. Yeah. And just one last question for you. You focus on meaning in life. So have you, do you feel like you found meaning in your life?
不，刚开始的人，比如本科生选修一门助人技巧的课程。研究生选修一门助人技巧的课程。所以这真的是试图弄清楚如何帮助他们磨练现有的技能，成为更好的沟通者，更好的治疗师。是的。还有最后一个问题想问你。你专注于生命的意义。所以你，你觉得你已经在生活中找到意义了吗？
Well, it's such a good way that you phrased that question. because I don't think anybody ever finds meaning. I think it's a process of constructing meaning on a daily basis, like we talked about before. So I don't think I would say I've found meaning. I think some moments I feel a couple days ago I felt like, wow, I feel like I'm actually in a groove and writing this book on helping skills just feels great.
嗯，你提出这个问题的方式真好。因为我认为没有人会真正“找到”意义。我认为这是一个每天构建意义的过程，就像我们之前讨论的那样。所以我不认为我会说我已经找到了意义。我觉得在某些时刻，几天前我觉得，哇，我觉得我真的进入状态了，写这本关于助人技巧的书感觉太棒了。
And other times this huge despair of who cares, what difference does it all make? So I think it's a very moment. thing and realizing, you know, what have I contributed? Am I? So, but I also would say I'm incredibly privileged that I have a wonderful family. I have a wonderful job. I do things that I like to do. I only do what I want to do at this point. So I feel privileged and very fortunate to get to pursue what I want to pursue in terms of my meaning. I mean, I can change topics at any time. I can do dreams. I can do meaning.
而其他时候，则会有那种巨大的绝望感：谁在乎呢，这一切有什么区别？所以我觉得这是一个非常瞬息万变的事情，并且意识到，你知道，我贡献了什么？我是吗？所以，但我也要说，我非常幸运，我有一个美满的家庭。我有一份非常棒的工作。我做我喜欢做的事。在这一点上，我只做我想做的事。所以我感到很特权，也很幸运能够去追求我想要追求的关于意义的东西。我的意思是，我可以随时改变话题。我可以做梦想。我可以做意义。
I can do psychotherapy. And it's not many people have that kind of freedom and to get to be around smart students to get to do research. I mean, it's just a fabulous career in psychology. And I like how you said it too about as a journey, not a destination. I mean,
我可以做心理治疗。没有多少人有那种自由，能和聪明的学生在一起，去进行研究。我的意思是，这在心理学领域是一个极好的职业。而且我也喜欢你关于它是一段旅程而不是目的地的说法。我的意思是，
it sounds like, oh, he's such a cliche. Sometimes there's so many things. It's about the journey not of the destination. But they said it's true. There are some days that are great and you're feeling on top of the world. Some days you're just feeling like blah,
听起来，哦，这太老生常谈了。有时有太多的事情。这就是过程而不是目的地。但他们说得对。有些日子好极了，你觉得自己站在世界之巅。有些日子你只是觉得平淡无奇，
you know, like what's the point? What's the point? What difference does make? Whoever you know, I look at an article. I wrote nobody's ever read it even. You know, it's like, why did I bother? Yeah.
你知道，就像有什么意义？有什么意义？这有什么区别？不管是谁，你知道，我看着我写的一篇文章，甚至从来没有人读过。你知道，就像，我为什么要费心呢？是的。
But like I really think it's helpful. You talked about just looking at the day to day and over a period of time. Right. And not just like looking at the, you know, the day to day things. But I think like self-full, I also like you said, just to look at how different things connect to your values and what's important to your life. And if it's not important, maybe that's a place for reevaluating and seeing. you know, where you can do something that makes you feel like it's connecting with what's important
但我真的觉得这很有帮助。你谈到了只需审视日常以及一段时间以来的情况。对。而不仅仅是看着，你知道，日常的事情。但我觉得就像自我充实一样，我也很喜欢你说的，只需审视不同的事情如何与你的价值观以及对你生活重要的事情联系起来。如果它并不重要，也许那就是重新评估并看看的地方，
to you. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. Then we have to make changes. Yeah. And that's hard. And that's the part, I think, you know, I think. But it's important. I imagine a lot of people have a deep sense within them if they really examine it, that there probably is a desire to feel like they have a meaning in life. They have a purpose. Yeah. I think, I think, I think it is inherent in our, you know, the way we're wired to want to have meaning. Even if there is no meaning, we need to make it so that we can feel like we are doing something in life. Yes, absolutely. Yeah, I think that's really true. Thank you so much for this fascinating conversation, Dr. Curl. I really enjoyed having you on the podcast. It's great fun. Thank you. If you've been a long-time listener or if you're
你知道，你可以在哪里做一些让你觉得与对你重要的事情相连的事情。完全正确。完全正确。是的。然后我们必须做出改变。是的。这很难。这就是那部分，我想，你知道，我认为。但这很重要。我想象很多人内心深处如果真正审视它，可能会有一种强烈的愿望，希望能感受到他们有生命的意义。他们有目标。是的。我想，我想，我想这是我们内置的，你知道，我们渴望拥有意义的这种天性。即使没有任何意义，我们也需要创造它，这样我们才能觉得我们在生活中做着某些事情。是的，绝对的。是的，我觉得确实如此。非常感谢库尔博士带来的精彩对话。我真的很享受你来到这个播客。非常有趣。谢谢。如果你是一个老听众或者如果你是
new to our podcast, please consider giving us a rating in iTunes or if you have time, write a review. We'd really appreciate it. Also, like I mentioned, the beginning, of the show, we'd love to hear from you directly. So if you have any questions, comments, or ideas to share, please email me at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-A-D-Rg. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes the podcast's APA Journal's dialogue
我们播客的新听众，请考虑在iTunes上给我们评分，或者如果你有时间，写一篇评论。我们将不胜感激。另外，就像我在节目开始时提到的，我们很乐意直接听到您的声音。因此，如果您有任何问题、意见或想法要分享，请给我发电子邮件：K-Luna@APA.org。那是K-L-U-N-A@APA.org。“心理学话你知”（Speaking of Psychology）是美国心理学协会（APA）播客网络的一部分，其中包括“APA期刊对话”（APA Journals Dialogue）
about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcast on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, speakingof-psychology.org, to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于新的心理学研究，以及关于心理学实践的“进度记录”（Progress Notes）。您可以在iTunes、Stitcher或您获取播客的任何地方找到我们的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站speakingof-psychology.org收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学协会的凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。